herr Fuchs auf dem Weg zur Arbeit komme
ich immer in einer Hauswand vorbei und
auf diese Hauswand ist gesprüht es ist
nicht unser Krieg und dann sehen Sie
hier auf das Bild übersprüht wütend fast
ein dickes doch dieses Bild finde ich
bildet so viel ab nach einem Jahr Krieg
was würden Sie sagen ist das unser Krieg
ich würde sagen es ist unser Krieg ob
wir es wollen oder nicht
weil Putin nicht nur der Ukraine sondern
auf dem Westen den Krieg erklärt hat und
weil dieser Krieg nicht darauf abzielt
die Ukraine zu unterwerfen
oder zumindest ein großes Stück aus der
Ukraine herauszubrechen
sondern es ist auch eine Attacke auf die
europäische Friedensordnung ist eine
Attacke auf das Völkerrecht ist eine
Attacke und auf die Grundwerte auf den
europaaufbaut und auch auf unsere
künftige Sicherheit wenn Putin mit
diesem Krieg durchkommt wird es nicht
der letzte sein sondern dann wird der
nächste wahrscheinlich auf
nahtoderatorium ausgetragen werden wenn
ihre Familie auch unser Krieg
also es ist auf jeden Fall ein Krieg der
die ganze Weltbevölkerung betrifft wir
haben Veränderungen in den ökonomischen
Beziehungen wir haben ein Zunahme von
Armut und Elend im globalen Süden auch
wegen der gestiegenen
Nahrungsmittelpreise deswegen gibt es
auch ein allgemeines Weltinteresse das
dieser Krieg möglichst rasch zum Ende
kommt und er ist insofern unser Krieg
als er auf europäischen Boden
stattfindet und wir die Hoffnung hatten
nach dem Ende des Kalten Krieges dass
wir eine stabile Friedensordnung
entwickeln bei der so etwas nicht mehr
möglich ist aber derjenige der das daran
gesprüht hat an die Hauswand der Merkel
der Markt im Sinn gehabt haben nicht zu
erklären warum dieser Krieg unser Leben
beeinflusst sondern er wollte ein
Statement sagen und sagt wir wollen uns
oder wir sollen uns da raushalten und
dann ist das übersprüht worden und mit
dem gegenteiliges Statement nee das ist
eben doch unser Krieg das zeigt im
Moment die Zerrissenheit auch hier in
Deutschland
wir haben ein ethisches Dilemma das muss
man ganz klar sagen bei Milosevic
wurde wie Kriegspartei als Milosevic die
Kosovaren
vertrieben hat mit Morden Anfang anfing
und da haben wir eingegriffen und das
war richtig so hier haben wir auch ein
Klick Putins dann ein Überfall auf ein
Opfer das keinerlei anders dazu gegeben
hat außer dass es auf seiner eigenen
Lebensart
europäisch zu sein frei zu sein zu
wollen und einen demokratischen Weg
gehen zu wollen darauf behaart hat
und dieser Überfall insofern
müssten wir eigentlich ethisch
so handeln wie wärmelocevic wir können
es nicht weil Russland Atom macht ist da
gibt es eine Grenze weil das nun
wirklich dann eine Linie ist die wir
nicht überschreiten dürft deshalb denke
ich müssen wir alles dafür tun um die
Ukraine zu unterstützen dass sie sich
wehren kann wir müssen Perspektiven neu
Bedenken auch für die Ukraine auch für
diese Lebensart was da heißt das
Demokratie und dergleichen insofern ist
es wirklich auch unser Krieg denn wir
sind mit gemeint unter stimme ich halt
fix zu weil klar ist Demokratie und all
diese unsere Werte die internationale
Ordnung werden angegriffen und hier ist
es so wichtig dass wir geschlossen
stehen unser Krieg oder nicht unser
Krieg bisher versteht bleiben wie nehmen
sie im Moment die Bevölkerung hier in
Deutschland war wie zerrissen wie
gespalten wie polarisiert die
Gesellschaft auch ihre Gemeinde also so
polarisiert wie das jetzt klingt sind
wir glaube ich nicht sondern in der Tat
nehme ich war das eine große Zahl von
Menschen gerade auch in den Kirchen
sagen als erstes sind die Menschen die
zu uns kommen die die uns angehen die
geflüchteten in ganz vielen christlichen
evangelischen kirchlichen Gemeinden sind
Menschen untergekommen und natürlich
geht uns das an wenn eine Nachbarn
überfallen natürlich ganz genau so in
den Schulen in den Kitas vielen
Gemeinden Stelle gefunden so ist es und
das geht uns an und genauso geht uns an
dass die Freiheit des ukrainischen
Volkes die Freiheit der Menschen die
hier einfach überfallen worden sind
immer auch eine Frage nach unserer
Freiheit in diesem Europa ist so wir
Füchs am Anfang gesagt hat wenn Putin
mit diesem Krieg durchkommt dann wird
sich die Weltordnung in der Tat auch in
Europa völlig verändert gerade so
gespalten so polarisiert ist das Land
gar nicht nehmen das ein bisschen anders
war in diesen Tagen und an dem
Wochenende ist eine sehr große
Demonstration angesagt hier in Berlin
Schweiz zwei mehrere Demonstration
ohnehin im ganzen Land aber eine
möglicherweise besonders große Alice
Nutzer und Sahra Wagenknecht haben sie
mit initiiert und gehen auf die Straße
in nieder Rumänien haben sie verstanden
wofür eigentlich also ich bin in
Cambridge
in dieser Woche und werde da mein neues
Buch vorstellen Siri auf practical
riesen das passt vielleicht hier zum
Thema sie werden da auf keinen Fall sein
beide Demonstration die fragt sie aber
nicht weil sie mit verhaften wollte für
diese Demonstration sondern haben sie
verstanden wofür die auf die Straße geht
ja also den den Text wenn man liest ist
er ziemlich eindeutig der Text
jedenfalls was immer man vielleicht noch
an politischen Motiven da vermuten mag
ich meine alle schwarze und Wagenknecht
da mir nicht dieselbe politische
Auffassung und es gibt ja noch ein paar
andere mit Initiatoren offensichtlich
wie z.B der frühere vizekommissions- und
so weiter
Käßmann von der evangelischen Seite und
so also wenn man den Text liest dann
geht es darum dass es zu einem möglichst
baldigen Friedensschluss aufgerufen wird
zugleichen Zeit auch der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg Putins
verurteilt wird
und unnötiges Blut vergießen wenn ich es
richtig in Erinnerung habe nicht weiter
stattfinden soll das ist eigentlich die
Botschaft worüber man sprechen muss und
dass in einem solchen Aufruf natürlich
nicht enthalten wie sollen eigentlich
die nächsten Schritte sein wie stellt
ihr euch das genau vor vielleicht
sprechen wir ja das ist der
Sendungstitel wenn er nieder will mir
das gerade ihrem Eindruck nachgehen
diese zwei und die Masse die dort
erwartet wird am Wochenende für den
Frieden auf die Straße oder eher für den
kremme
faktisch würde ich sagen greifen sie
Partei für den Kreml wenn sie fordern
die Einstellung der Waffenlieferungen an
die Ukraine das ist der Dreh und
Angelpunkt man kann unterschiedlicher
Auffassungen darüber sein ob ein
Waffenstillstand jetzt die richtige
Forderung ist die Ukraine lehnen das ab
ich verstehe sehr gut warum dass sie
keinen eingefrorenen Konflikt haben
wollen bei dem
weite Teile ihres Territoriums und der
russische Vorherrschaft kommen mit dem
entsprechenden Terror-Regime was damit
verbunden ist das ja nicht ein Ende der
Gewalt so oder ob dieser Krieg von der
Ukraine letztlich gewonnen werden muss
und wir Sie möglichst unterstützen
müssen aber ihr die Waffen zu verweigern
das bedeutet dass man faktisch Partei
für den Aggressor ergreift ja wenn man
eine verhandlungsfrieden will dann muss
man die Ukraine möglichst stark machen
weil die russische Führung erst bereit
sein wird die territoriale Integrität
und politisch Souveränität der Ukraine
anzuerkennen wenn sie am Rande einer
Niederlage steht vorher wird Putin seine
Kriegsziele nicht aufgeben jetzt da Herr
Merkel ihrem Eindruck nach um Frieden
oder geht es auch um die Frage auch bei
den vielen die da mitlaufen werden lass
uns alleine lass uns in Ruhe mit dem
ganzen Kram ihr könnt das Sterben
Hauptsache wir haben unseren Wohlstand
also ich kann nicht ausschließen dass
solche Leute mitlaufen bei den beiden
Autorinnen glaube ich das nicht und
trotzdem glaube ich dass es dich zu Ende
gedacht ist denn was heißt dann also
einmal stimme ich dem Sud dass wir
natürlich unterstützen müssen und er
sage ich mit allem was militärisch nötig
ist damit die Ukraine sich verteidigen
kann das ist mein erster Satz in der
zweite ist
dann wenn man nach Verhandlungen ruft
dann ist das allererste Jahr dass man
diesen Brief eigentlich an Putin
schicken muss und dann wenn er bereit
ist zu wahre beziehungsweise
zurückzuziehen
dann muss man gucken wie kann man das
stabilisieren oder man muss werden über
den Kopf von der Ukraine hinweg wird man
nicht verhandeln können
insofern ist das dann zu allererst eine
Frage an die Ukraine und auch das ist
eben schon gesagt worden ein Verlust und
wir alle ich habe noch keinen Start
jetzt gefunden der jetzt sagt
der Verlust der Krim was wir alle nicht
anerkannt haben oder in der Ostukraine
all diese Gebiete würden jetzt nicht
mehr zu Ukraine gehören wollen wir etwa
sagen wir sollen und dann da wohnen
Menschen und wir haben es ein Butscher
und an vielen Orten erlebt was dort
passiert wenn Russen dort die Herrschaft
haben und von daher kann das in meinen
Augen kein Rat sein anhand dieser lensky
sozusagen die sind dann nicht mehr egal
und von daher sage ich ja von daher es
ist nicht zu Ende gedacht glaube ich
darauf was sagen sie zu dem zu diesem ja
offenbaren Zweckbündnis Wagenknecht
schwarze was halten Sie davon
also ich glaube dass da eine neue
politische Allianz sich herausbildet die
von ganz links
Wagenknecht Flügel der Linkspartei also
die alte anti-nato anti-amerikanische
Tradition bis ganz rechts
also bis zur sagen AFD und dazwischen
sind Leute die tatsächlich glauben dass
es nichts Wichtigeres gibt als dass die
Waffen heute Schweigen mit denen muss
man sich auseinandersetzen was bedeutet
eigentlich Frieden ja ist Frieden
einfach das Aufhören von Krieg oder
bedeutet Frieden auch ein Leben in
Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit für die
Ukraine ja und mit den Menschen die
pazifistischer Gesinnung sind die sagen
den Krieg furchtbar finden wir alle
jeder Krieg ist eine humanitäre
Katastrophe das ist doch gar keine Frage
und trotzdem gibt es notwendige Kriege
und es gibt gerechte Kriege und deshalb
muss man mit den Ringen während ich
glaube dass die beiden politischen
Flügel die das jetzt sagen vorantreiben
wir sind nicht nur
Vertreter einer pro russischen Situation
die sind meines Erachtens auch eine
Gefahr für die liberale Demokratie kann
sowas egal sein bei einer Demonstration
Werder mitläuft dass man damit dann
nicht ja hat man trägt man dafür keine
Verantwortung oder muss man sich eben
doch schwarzer und Wagenknecht ab und zu
umdrehen wer da hinterherläuft ich
glaube man muss mindestens als
Veranstalter sehr klar positionieren und
dann auch abgrenzen man ist dann auch
vom vor dem Beifall von der falschen
Seite nie ganz gefeit das ist klar aber
die klare Abgrenzung muss erfolgen und
die vermisse ich an dieser Stelle auch
trotzdem will ich an dieser Stelle
einmal auch für meine Kolleginnen Margot
kästnerstelle nein an dieser Stelle will
ich erstmal deutlich sagen auch sie geht
aus einer großen Frieden sucht an dieser
Stelle mit und wie Herr Fuchs gesagt hat
wir müssen dann darüber reden was
gerechter Frieden heißt und nur ein
gerechter Frieden hier drüber gespielt
ein Name der diesen Frieden verdient
habe ich bisher noch nicht will ich aber
unbedingt jetzt in dieser Woche noch
machen es ist ja nicht meine Position
aus der Herausforderung auf die Straße
gegangen wird das will ich klar sagen
aber ich will den Menschen jedenfalls
Margot Käßmann und vielen anderen auch
nicht die Sehnsucht nach Frieden
absprechen genau darüber muss diskutiert
werden wir haben das Leitbild vom
gerechten Frieden in der evangelischen
Friedensethik in den letzten Jahrzehnten
entwickelt und stehen jetzt an dieser
Stelle auch sozusagen vor einer
Situation in der das neue justiert und
neue präzise bestimmt werden muss weil
um jetzt mal eine andere auch sehr
bekannte evangelische Christen zur
zitieren weil auch vor geringer hat
sagten nur ein gerechter Frieden einer
in Freiheit kann dann auch Frieden
genannt werden insofern der Streit geht
tief durch die evangelische Kirche
Gesellschaft geht der geht auch tief
durch die Grüne Partei wenn gleich ja
gibt es auch margottes man auch
sicherlich eher
Seminar in jeder geht auch tief durch
die durch die SPD sie waren damals
Kulturstaatsminister als Gerhard
Schröder auch Nein zum Irakkrieg gesagt
hat sie ziehen viele Parallelen zu der
Zeit damals in ihren Aufsätzen damals
war ein Satz mit dem Gerd Schröder auch
in den Wahlkämpfen die Herzen zugeflogen
ist Solidarität ja aber Abenteuer nein
ist dieser Satz heute aktuell würden Sie
sagen ja der ist aktuell der ist immer
aktuell die Frage ist
zu entscheiden was geboten ist hängt den
hohem Maße davon ab was der Fall ist
welche Fakten wir anerkennen müssen und
da gibt's unterschiedliche
Einschätzungen ich bin zum Beispiel kein
militär-experte ich kann das nur aus
zweiter Hand beurteilen diejenigen die
sagen es kann erst ein Frieden geben
wenn die Ukraine
gesiegt hat und zwar gesiegt im
umfassenden Sinne also Eroberung der
neueroberten Gebiete seit dem 24 Februar
letzten Jahres Eroberung der
Separatisten Gebiete im Osten wenn sie
es doch Befreiung Befreiung ja lass uns
mal das jetzt mal offen weil wir nicht
genau wissen wie die Bevölkerung dazu
russisch oder Ukrainisch stehen oder
eben
alle die ich gesprochen habe und die man
so seriös recherchieren kann ein
bisschen auf zum Oberbefehlshaber der
amerikanische Streitkräfte kommen in
seiner faktischen einzig das ist kein
ethische Stellungnahme zu der faktischen
Einstellung oder Einschätzung dass
dieser umfassende Sieg der Ukraine
militärisch nicht möglich ist man kann
vielleicht jetzt mal Vorsicht dick noch
was hinzufügen den kann militär-experte
vorsichtig hinzufügen wenn er mit sagen
wir mal einer Verzehnfachung der
westlichen Waffenlieferungen wie es ja
von der ukrainischen Seite gefordert
wurde
wenn es möglich wäre dann ist zu
vermuten dass spätestens bei der Frage
Krim
ist zu einer unkontrollierten Eskalation
dieses Konfliktes kommt das ist der
Punkt den Markus Meckel gerade
angesprochen hat weil diese nuklear
macht natürlich auch über taktische
Atomwaffen verfügt wenn sie dermaßen
stark in die Defensive kommt ist zu
befürchten sie setzt sie ein das ist
eine Fakten Frage die ich nicht wirklich
beurteilen kann mir fällt nur auf das
Militärexperten fast durchgängig vor
allem die Aktiven richtig fast
durchgängig dieser Auffassung sind jetzt
Moment wenn dem so ist wenn wir
tatsächlich zu erwarten haben dass hier
noch mal wenn es ein Jahr weitergeht ist
ein vor und zurückgeht mit vielleicht
noch mal
250.000 Toten auf beiden Seiten dann
muss man jetzt überlegen welche
Möglichkeiten gibt es diese Todesfälle
zu verhindern und trotzdem zu verhindern
da sind wir uns zum Beispiel völlig
einig hier am Tisch
dass es keinen diktatfrieden gibt das
Putin seine Kriegsziele nicht erreicht
deswegen machen wir keine Karikaturen
war ich der Meinung der Ukraine muss
geholfen werden auch mit Waffen geholfen
werden damit Putin seine Kriegsziele
nicht erreicht ich bin aber auch der
Meinung dass es unverantwortlich ist der
Illusion anzuhängen und einige an diesem
Tisch einmal politische Vergangenheit
die sehr stark mit Illusionen verbunden
waren zum Beispiel mauristischen
Illusionen sind sie gemeint ja höchsten
sie gemeint
ja diese Neigung sozusagen sich
Wunschbilder zu machen und dann danach
Politik zu machen ist hoch gefährlich
das vergisst man nicht das prägt
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen näher an den
ukrainischen Realität also jetzt mal
lassen Sie mich kurz hingehen wenn man
jetzt sagt wir müssen alles tun damit
weder die eine Seite noch die andere
Seite
jetzt erwarten kann umfassend zu siegen
weil nur dass die Chance beinhaltet
einen Ende des der Waffen
Auseinandersetzung zu haben dann heißt
das noch keineswegs das damit
entschieden ist was geschieht zum
Beispiel Rückzug Russlands vor die
Grenzen die es vorher also kontrolliert
hat vom 24 Februar das wäre ein
wichtiger Punkt zweitens warum redet
niemand darüber dass man vielleicht mal
die Bevölkerungen befragt wie die das
sehen und der Egide der Vereinten
Nationen auf der Krim oder in den beiden
Separatisten Gebiete im Osten warum rede
darüber niemand das haben wir im
Saarland so gemacht das war nicht
schlecht ist jetzt 55 entschieden
das muss absolut sauber sein ich meine
wir reden immer von Demokratie in der
internationalen Politik spielt auf meine
Demokratie keine mehr wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie